with more than 2 million border
crossings this fiscal year the highest
ever on record we're live in Del Rio
Texas this morning to get the first-hand
account on how Biden's border crisis is
affecting both this community and the
country joining us now National border
patrol council president Brandon Judd
and Fox News contributor and host of
dark wars the Border podcast Sarah
Carter can't wait to hear that podcast
sounds exciting
um so I'm going to start with you
Brandon just this year 98 known
terrorists that's what we've caught
that's correct so we don't know how many
more have made it into the interior
um this is a national security issue why
isn't this the top news it is a national
security issue and that's what's so
frustrating to all border patrol agents
we understand what is coming across that
border we see it every single day we
should be dealing with between 30 to 40
000 apprehensions per per month
um and and typically that's single
adults not family units not children but
what's happening is our hands are
completely tied and so the Smugglers are
able to get across anything that they
want to get across whether that's
fentanyl or like you just said people
from special interest countries that
want to do us harm this border security
crisis could be solved tomorrow but this
Administration has no political will so
we don't know who's coming into the
country we don't know what harm is going
to be done this is going to be felt
years down the road and we're all going
to look back at this and we're going to
say it could have been solved but the
Biden Administration wanted to Pander to
politics wanted to place their open open
border base I still remember when uh
former president Donald Trump said they
were that terrorists were coming over
the southern border and people laughed
at him on the other side and we now know
it's true and it's not making big news
outside of fox um it's amazing to me uh
I want to talk to you about the cartels
because you had in the mate last time we
had you on you had a jaw-dropping
interview with a cartel member I don't
know how you got access it was amazing
which is why people should watch your
podcast
um because you do a great job uh you
this cartel member said that it isn't
just child human trafficking sex
trafficking he talked about the sale of
child organs I mean right this is some
dark evil stuff and we're now empowering
the cartels that they're more powerful
than ever
thank you for saying that because that's
exactly what's happening when I'm out on
the border or when I travel to Central
America when I talk to the people and
you're right I did get access to a
coyote a Smuggler
um I think I would I could consider him
a little bit higher level because he was
in El Salvador and his story is about
not just moving people across three
countries right into the United States
but taking children how the cartels in
Mexico are literally taking a lot of the
children they are harvesting their
organs they are using them in the most
horrific ways imaginable and I was able
to verify this through DEA I was able to
verify this through U.S intelligence I
mean what are we doing here and why is
the Biden Administration allowing this
to happen in fact it is their policy
they're complicit in it that's exactly
they're doing the last leg of the of the
cartels work by moving people with our
tax dollars into the interior moving
them into the interior Rachel and think
about this you talked about all of the
no you know the known godaways but we
have not been able to vet right imagine
what's coming into our children's
schools imagine the people that are
coming into the country the criminals I
know Brandon and I spent so much time
out on the border I see them all the
time but this is this is a serious
situation that has evolved from he said
twenty thousand twenty thousand to
thirty thousand a month to now 230 000 a
month yeah Brandon so once the children
and I want to stick on children because
I just we had so many members of
Congress on the other side on the on the
Democrat side crying outside of
detention centers our government is
losing track of 40 percent absolutely of
the children that we process um this is
this is a crime I mean this is
unbelievable that this is not Front Page
News it is and every single time a
border patrol agent takes these
individuals into custody like I had a
Tommy tuberville on the senator
tuberville on the on the border just
yesterday and he got to see exactly what
it's coming across he got to see the
children that are in custody and
whenever we take those individuals in
custody we see what's happening to them
we feel it and and to know that this
Administration isn't doing anything to
protect these vulnerable individuals
these women and children that are being
abused and raped and sometimes even
murdered in in Mexico or on their
Journey up and they're doing absolutely
nothing to stop this and again Rachel
there are solutions they just won't put
them into place we had a panel yesterday
I asked and it was a mix it was
Hispanics whites Independence Democrats
Republicans all from here in Del Rio I
asked them if they thought the Border
was open they said all of them raise
their hand yes the borders open then I
asked them if they thought the Biden
policy was intentional and they all
raised their hand all of that Democrats
included so um this is a this is a very
dangerous policy and we'll have to have
you guys back because um this it's it's
criminal what's happening to our country
and to the sent victims coming across oh
absolutely and for all the children out
there that are lost and all the children
that have lost their lives imagine what
what that's like for them and thank you
guys for both um covering that this
story it's important thank you Rachel
Brandon Judd Sarah Carter thank you so
much I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade
and I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis